حذر مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكيه للشؤون
السياسيه كولين كال مما سماه نجاح روسيا
في الحرب باوكرانيا
واشارك خلال جلسه استماع عقدتها لجنه
القوات المسلحه في مجلس النواب الى ان
الولايات المتحده قدمت لاوكرانيا مساعدات
عسكريه تشكل ضعف ما قدمه حلفاء اخرون
نجحت روسيا في اوكرانيا او نظر اليها على
انها حققت اهدافها فان ذلك سيشجعوا معتدين
اخرين في اماكن اخرى على القيام بامور
مماثله النظام الدولي في اعتقادي يقوم على
مبدا السياده ووحده الاراضي وذلك هو قلب
ميثاق الامم المتحده هذا النظام القائم
على القواعد هو ما يقلل في النهايه من عدد
النزاعات والحروب الدوليه التي نراها اذا
سمح لدول مثل روسيا بالسير في اتجاه
ابتلاع جيرانها فسيستبدل مبدا سياده
القانون بقانون الغاب
وسنعيش في عالم شديد الخطوره